la tortue oui absolument
[Applaudissements]
et ben pourtant voilà ce qu'il a dit en
fait il a dit que ben on va regarder
où mais vraiment je pense que là il s'en
rappelle une émission sur une radio
publique mais là où quelqu'un a passé je
pense au moins trois quatre minutes
c'est très long radio 3-4 minutes à
faire tout un sketch une satire en
disant on a hâte que j'ai 28 ans pour
dire qu'en fin vous baiser avec des mecs
parce qu'on sait tous depuis le début il
y a vous qui est pas con et tout un
sketch comme ça pendant trois quatre
minutes et je dis tellement choqué mais
vraiment et en fait le gars je vais les
fracasser j'ai fracassé j'ai dit à la
différence entre vous et moi vous êtes
payés pour défoncer les gens et vous
avez besoin de faire une fiche pour
sortir votre merde moi j'ai pas besoin
de faire une fiche pour vous exploser en
5 minutes et donc là je vais railler les
gars directement ça vous lui dites à
l'antenne ou après l'émission on a eu
pour pour leur argent pour le coup mais
parce que au bout d'un moment les gens
ont l'impression que parce que vous êtes
connu parce que vous êtes en une servi
en interview vous devez aussi recevoir
ce déversement de merde parce qu'il y a
pas d'autres mots parce que simplement
si vous répondez vous êtes quelqu'un de
prétentieux et tout mais vous dites
juste mais stop en fait dans la vie le
mec me parle comme ça je une droite
[Musique]
on a essayé toute la semaine de savoir
peut-être Christopher vous serez en fait
pour que les gens comprennent vous
travaillez où c'est depuis 10 jours
médias en intermittent les piges
exactement exactement donc vous avez des
impôts aussi médias oui est-ce que vous
savez que c'est de quelle chroniqueur il
parle non c'est moi c'est normal c'est
ça ce qui m'intéresse c'est
bon
il est choqué qu'on lui pose ce genre de
questions mais après enfin c'est le
métier d'un journaliste d'aller chercher
là où on a envie d'avoir la croustillant
et des trucs un peu moi je suis Isabelle
complètement d'accord moi mon grand
combat c'est de dire que nous on a le
devoir de poser des questions et eux de
nous répondre ou de faire une chronique
mais c'est pas une citation à
comparaître donc des fois il y a un ton
que moi je trouve assez odieux parce
qu'on a on se prend pour des entre Dieu
et l'homme quoi et ça souvent c'est très
désagréable et je comprends qu'on nous
aime pas heureusement vous avez dit que
vous étiez gay parce que nous tout le
monde le savait c'est quand même un peu
forcé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
comment ça va mon cœur mon bébé ça va
les bébés ça c'est que tu es pas trop
été les prénoms
c'est que on peut faire un interview
être un bon journaliste sur une
interview sans rentrer dans les détails
de la vie privée ils sont
un composé de raconter des choses de sa
vie tranquille
humoristique après tu vas dans une radio
il y a un papier humoristique qui casse
un peu bah tu acceptes le truc et
surtout
mon cœur
quelqu'un intelligent voilà
mais c'est vrai qu'il faut être très
honnête et surtout maintenant
aujourd'hui spécialement celle-là celle
de Cyril et tout ça alors c'est pas le
cas de quotidien Aujourd'hui mission
mais ça gros raconte nos vies maintenant
tout le monde sait tous sur nous en
permanence quand même
on peut être assez malade il faut que tu
as fait l'amour
exactement c'était lundi dernier
[Applaudissements]